picture this you you have a fan who is a
biologist but like
an explorer and they've gone into the
amazon or in
the jungle in australia or somewhere in
the world and they've found a new
species
what would you want that species to be
and they're your fans so they want to
name it after you
so what is that animal it could be a
plant it could be a mineral if you
really want
but what would it be named and what
would it be
a plant or a mineral no no it's not
gonna be a plant or a mineral i despise
plants and minerals i won't eat a salad
and i think rocks are a huge waste of
time
uh and should be crushed into the
smallest size possible
um i do i've always been beef do you
have
i've been uh anti-rock my whole life and
what do they do they're just there and
everyone's like
look it's a rock um so no what an
important position
yeah well sorry i like to stake out
controversial positions and i'm not
afraid
um i get some online hate for my
anti-rock views but i'll stick by them
brenna first of all i love who said
picture this imagine there's a fan
and then you describe yourself to a t
a woman whose dad designs uh a dog toy
let's call it a glong um
and let's just imagine if you will that
she studied reptiles
uh and is maybe gonna study reptiles
again and go to say australia
the only place you've been so you're not
fooling anyone brenna it's clear that
that was your way of telling me you're a
huge fan and
uh you know you just were too
embarrassed to say it i think that you
got
me yeah got you what would i want i
would want
i have to say when i was over in
australia
i loved those animals
uh that just sort of hang around you
know like your sloths
or your what's the one that the koalas
the koalas
i like a real chill animal but i think
that
most people wouldn't associate that with
me no
so it's probably gonna have to be some
kind of a lemur
a lemur with darting steve buscemi eyes
yeah and it's like me it's hyped up it
thinks way too much
it's it's on something um
and it's hyper it doesn't live as long
as other mammals
uh but it's super jittery and it's got a
lot of ideas and it talks too much
that would be the animal that i would
want am i describing an animal that
actually exists
yeah based off of what you're saying and
like short-lived
kind of just like goes for it and is
also kind of orange
um i never said orange i never said it
i never said orange i never said orange
and you really hit the short live thing
let's not hit that too hard
you said so many things and short-lived
is what she went off of
okay because i had in my mind i was
thinking of a qual which is an
australian mammal
that only lives for about a year okay
well yeah but
what a year i mean i know it's only
alive for a year but the
female quales know it's only around for
a year so they
he's got like a bad boy reputation he's
like a james dean they know
and so he gets a lot of action he hits
it and quits it
pretty much yeah right so it's a qual
yeah it's really cool you should look it
up and see what it looks like sometime
yeah sona do that for me i don't look
things up
uh qual how do you spell that q-u-o-l-l
q-u-o-l-l that's what i want i want to
be a species of qual
oh my god let me see it oh god let me
check it out let me take a look at this
poll here
it's not cute it is cute uh cute
you know what i want to say it is an
exotic rat
it's not red it's not it's a wrap it
looks
like i'm telling you what it looks like
oh does that mean it has a pouch if it's
a marsupial
yes okay look at me oh you got a pouch
um yeah so it's it looks like a rat
that's traveled a lot in europe has
family money
and has a fanny pack i.e pouch that's
what the qual looks like and you know
what we have to name a call after
me conan o'brien that's what i want i
want i want the call
why does it only live for a year does it
ride a motorcycle what is it what
what's the problem with the qual you
know i was talking to my professor about
this and i had these same questions and
i'm not entirely sure if i got the
answer or if i just don't remember
but
[Laughter]
i love your honesty my professor told me
uh
he either uh i don't know i don't think
i was listening
but we were on a camping trip and he
studies spotted quaals in australia
and it's like one of the shortest life
spans of any mammal
so i think they just you know they get
what they need done
quickly yes you have to be efficient
yeah
that's if i was a qual and people would
were saying to me
hey conan do you mind i wanna hey hey i
got a year i got a year no
i'm not no i'm not gonna tell you which
cork board i prefer
yeah that's your decision i don't have
time for this yeah what would you be do
you like working on your novel
no you just you said yourself hitting it
and quitting it all the time
living life to the edge i would be
traveling constantly so many drugs
ah man to be a qual
it's only a year but what a year